voyage thank you mr albrecht commission
president you have the floor
thank you so much
many questions
for the beginning indeed
the first question you asked was on the
lessons learned with the vaccines
and if there's one lesson we have
learned with the vaccines is
for huge
global challenges
the one and only
way to address them is
as 27 with unity
just imagine for a second
that all 27 member states would have
gone on their own
what the vaccines are concerned then
three or four member states perhaps
would have had vaccines the rest would
not have had any access to vaccines it
would have completely destroyed our
european union
so the first lesson is indeed the big
challenges will much better together if
we act united of course we develop
strategies um or also structures that
are necessary after this pandemic for
example hera for example the health
union so we understand that we have
improved and adapt and modernize our
structures
what the budgetary issues are concerned
indeed we have a tight budget without
any doubt i have not forgotten the
negotiations around the budget and it's
tight and it's programmed now and it's
very much allocated to the different
topics and now we see how it is
when you have almost no wiggle room
because there's no extra money we cannot
print money there's no free money so
it's very much uh bound
and indeed with a midterm review we have
to check we have to look what have we
done what is ahead of us are we still on
track with what we have allocated
but there's a third element in your
question
referring to next generation eu
why did we
form or develop next generation eu
because we understood
the crisis is so huge
the crisis is so dominant
that with the usual means and
instruments and fund allocation we are
not able to manage it
so we did the one and only correct thing
that we said let's do it as 27 europeans
together and what we did better compared
to the financial crisis for example
there the solution was intergovernmental
so it was just the the prescription for
fragmentation that you could see
this time we had trust on the european
level
27 member states backing the european
commission to raise capital on the
market and the rest of
the elements you very much know
so
this shows that yes we have our budget
we have our usual procedures for but for
extraordinary situations we sometimes
need extraordinary means and step
forward finally
um i don't i cannot see my time because
there's so many
so no i've i'm already way over my time
sorry you but i need a little hole to
see the the seconds there and honorable
members if you uh if it's fine with you
i remain standing because i have a
medical issue on my back so it's better
for me i remain standing and look at you
lectern would be fine too but no i think
we we agreed on this year this way thank
you very much no supplementary question
from mr albrecht i see or one quickly 30
seconds
exactly by the way
madam president we are not speaking
about meeting review but medium revision
but my question what what about this
stress test i mean the the
revision of
legislative which is existing in future
thank you
not if it's appropriate because um you
know things you have um you have done in
the past might have been good for the
past but the question and this is the
stress test element is it fit for
purpose is it fit for the future why not
is my answer
thank you very much
thank you very much the next speaker on
behalf of snd group is ira garcia perez
[Music]
a thank you president you have the floor
thank you so much
indeed the core value and
the hallmark
of the european union is its social
market economy
nowhere in the world do you have this
exclusive and phenomenal model as we
have it here
which is very clear and it's the success
model after world war ii
to say we all work hard together but the
benefits of our work is being evenly
distributed
so there are checks and balances and you
know the elements from employer
associations to trade unions
to figure out how the right where the
right balance is and the second topic
which is for me of utmost importance
and that is the social security system
the social security system that says
everybody pays in
and we make sure
that the big risks in life you're not
let down you're not alone but we support
you it's poverty
it's made old age
it might be health
or sickness
so these topics unemployment are covered
and i am deeply convinced that this is
one of the secrets why the european
union is so successful and why the
single market is so successful
and therefore it's always important to
contribute to it
you have been uh asking about the
unemployment reinsurance the sure
element
which was crucial crucial
during the pandemic is a typical
unemployment reinsurance
because it had all the elements that
were necessary to say
to the companies or to signal to the
companies
don't
dismiss
your employees in the times of crisis
and we support you keeping them in the
company even there is if there is not
enough work to do
because we know at the end of this
crisis
skilled labor will be crucial to
jump back again and to
move forward to growth again
and it was the right thing to do
it was around about 100 billion i think
94.95 billion have been allocated to 19
member states and that was one of the
reason
why
in the
um i was about to say in the aftermath
of the pandemic but we are not there yet
when things got better
after the worst part of the pandemic our
economy bounced back so
rapidly because we had the skilled
personnel and could immediately take on
the orders that came worldwide
of course there are other topics
that we have to or had worked on for
example the child guarantee just to name
one but also in the agenda uh where we
had uh to fight child poverty social
exclusion you know that member states
should at least use five percent of
their esf plus resources
um i
thanks a lot that this is now a law
that is put in place here without your
help it would not have been possible
and there are other topics will
certainly i see my times again short
we'll certainly talk again about
thank you very much
30 seconds
is
[Music]
thank you president
so the minimum wage directive is on its
way as you know
and
i think it has
a fair chance
and i hope
it will be concluded
it is important
for the minimum wage for example to
really have a look at what we are asking
for
i'm a deep believer
of collective collective bargaining this
is in my way in my in my eyes the right
way to go forward for a minimum wage and
this is what is in the proposal so it's
very clearly signaling to those member
states and we have many of them
that have already a good collective
bargaining system in place
to tell them you're fine
that's a good system keep on going with
that and it works we've seen that
but to those where this is not uh in
place and where there is not really any
kind of protection to the lower level of
the income
there we signal very clearly put in
place if possible a bargaining a
collective bargaining system if possible
the best is with employer unions and
trade unions
if not there are suggestions how to come
to a minimum wage that strikes the right
balance not to be too low not to be too
high in the circumstances a member state
needs so we've proposed i think a good
model
it is also something which creates
fairness among the member states and uh
the market of 27 and if there's anything
we've learned
then it is our single market functions
best
if it's well balanced if there's
fairness in it if it is harmonious also
in its rules but this is another topic
so um to
finish and to conclude the minimum wage
directive would be absolutely a goal to
go for
thank you very much i now give the floor
to stefan sejuni
pardon
thank you very much president
indeed
we had a cascade of crises
and
looking back now to these two and a half
years
i remember i we had 95 days
in the mandate when uh the pandemic hit
well and you all know we are two and a
half years in the mandate and now we
have a war
at our doorstep
we have fixed three priorities at the
very beginning the european green deal
and this is the huge big enormous crisis
looming in the back
and ongoing getting more and more
serious more and more severe if you read
the world climate council
comments yesterday and today you're
aware of that
and then we had the other crisis i was
just talking about
so the european green deal absolutely
necessary first priority and we'll
certainly speak in depth in this
question time about it
digital self-explaining
resilient
well had i known before
what is hidden behind the word resilient
now resilience now we know it
what have we done we have not only had
uh the pandemic common strategy and
actually we are world leaders what the
effects are concerned we have exported 2
billion
doses of vaccines in comparison just to
give you that china 1.2 billion
we have the population the best
vaccinated population for a region like
we are with 450 million european 72
percent
now boosted and 52 excuse me 72 fully
vaccinated and 52 boosted
we have um
been working on the resilience in the
health union
now indeed to come to the part in your
question um looking back and looking
forward
uh is it still the right priorities my
answer is absolutely yes
but within the resilience part i would
emphasize stronger european defense
and
a conducive environment for our
single market
focusing on the modern elements that we
need for example hydrogen for example
semiconductors we will certainly also
speak in depth about that in the in the
question time
but the general approach approach
european green deal digital and
resilience is the right one with new um
emphasis in the resilience part on
defense and on the continuous conducive
economic environment
thank you very much do you have a
supplementary question mr junior
[Music]
up
i guess then two minutes but i'll start
um first of all
it was a big step forward to have the
rule of law report
with the individual reporting on each
member state
and indeed
if we now
focus on
many different issues but the issues you
have mentioning
in poland and in
hungary
there are two main topics
in poland it is the question of the
independence of the judiciary
this is a big open question
where we are
we have an issue without any question
and as you know there is the article 7
procedure as we know we launched
infringements and as we know and i guess
we will discuss it we have the open
question of the resilience and recovery
fund
uh next generation eu which is not a
typical instrument to deal with
topics like that but it's an instrument
for reform
and we put in the request that a major
long-standing reform
necessity in poland is in the european
semester independence of judiciary so
happy to
follow up on that
with um hungary
we've been very clear the issue is
corruption
and
we have been very clear on
the article 7 procedure there are
infringements also on other topics
we have been discussing with hungary
questions that
are concerning the resilience and
recovery fund here the main requirement
for reform is
the anti-corruption
question
and we are at the moment being not able
to find a common ground and to conclude
and then
uh with 13 seconds left there is the big
topic of
the question of the conditionality
mechanism and i'm happy to respond with
fresh time on that
thank you very much president next is
arnold dungeon
thank you president
and
this topic is an urgent topic
and we have certainly in a bitter way
learned our lessons we are learning our
lessons
just to get it right and this is very
important um always at the very
beginning
nato is the strongest military alliance
in the world and the european union will
never ever be a military alliance
but
i see fields where nato is necessary but
i also see other theaters or other
topics where the european union has to
be able to act and to
defend itself
interestingly as you know there's the
article
5 in nato and correspondent the article
42.7
now what is the reality on the ground
the reality on the ground is we have 22
member states that are member of nato
and we have 27 member states of course
being members of the european union
they all have one single set of forces
this is from the member states view
the the departure point they have one
single set of forces
and for them it's important that they
can if necessary allocate these forces
to a european mission to a nato mission
to a united nations missions or to a
coalition of the willing
from the european um perspective for us
is important to look at if we look at
our 27 member states
what can we do to stop the fragmentation
we do have between those 27
where are the gaps that have to be
filled with military capabilities
and what are capabilities we do not have
at all and we need to build up
and therefore if i take the last one big
topic for us cyber security
cyber security in the european union
must is a must and we have to get much
better and build up real
reliable structures
the second topic is if you look at the
military capabilities interoperability
can these different troops work together
immediately
well depends if they have the same
military equipment for that we have
created a system through pesco
and the european defense fund that is
nudging the member states
to have a common research and
development and to have a common
procurement or development of
capabilities
now what speed is concerned mid may the
commission will present a gap analysis
and this is the basis then from uh for
us to starting from that have the
discussion what is necessary what do we
have to build up how are we going to
build it up and how are we going to
finance it
thank you very much mr dungeon do you
want a supplementary question no thank
you next is gabby bishop
they get out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you president
definitely not
first of all
and i think it's just the opposite
i think these last
horrible
four to six weeks
have more than before shown us
how important the european green deal is
we have seen the
ugly dependency
on fossil fuels
so
moving away from fossil fuels
into renewables
and thus
moving forward in the european green
deal
is not only a necessity necessity what
because of the climate change we have to
fight
but it's also a strategic investment in
security
and therefore if there's anything there
are certainly three things where uh
putin did never calculate on the first
one is the unity that we've shown in the
european union the second one is the
braveness of the ukrainian
population and soldiers that's amazing
to see that the third one is
that he is giving a strong push to get
rid of the dependency of fossil fuels
and to move forward
to
to the strategic investment in
renewables
if we just take
fit455 that has been designed before the
war
fit for 55 if we would go on as it is
and we will not because we will
accelerate so we need more of it if we
would only do that it would already be
one third of our dependency of russian
fossil fuels
the second step what we've done is
diversify away from the russians
into yes you're right liquefied gas
that's true
but we do that because we also know we
need it right now but it's also the
infrastructure that is fit for purpose
for the green hydrogen
therefore the agreement i uh made
together with the american president joe
biden is
not only about lng but also about our
common goal to as soon as possible
replace the gas by green hydrogen in the
infrastructure that we are investing
together so two examples that show that
if there's anything that happens
this war also
pushes us
rightly so away from the dependency from
fossil fuels into the right way to go
forward uh to investment in the
renewables and therefore the european
green deal is
as needed as never before thank you very
much philip you want to come back
i well two minutes
and otherwise perhaps i can have a
little bit more
um indeed
and i hinted already at that um that
looking at hungary
we now have to look at the topic of
conditionality mechanism it is enforced
since january 21
not a single case is lost i want to be
very clear here otherwise we would not
be today able to do what we want to do
we have prepared the guidelines many
thanks for the support here in doing
that
and you have seen the ecj ruling that
was reassuring that the court fully
confirmed the approach
followed followed by the commission
but they also underlined that it's
always needed to inform the member
states and give them and this is of
course also rule of law give them the
opportunity to explain and to answer
questions
that's what we've done
we've sent a letter to hungary with
questions
they have answered
and we've carefully assessed the result
of these questions and our
conclusion is we have to move on the
next step
and therefore the commissioner han has
today
spoken to the hungarian authorities and
informed them
that we will now send the letter of
formal notification to start the
conditionality mechanism
[Applause]
as you know this triggers a
procedure
that has specific timelines um so
a process is going on now
thank you very much esther delanges next
yes thank you madam president madam
commission president uh president you
already touched upon uh the fact that
the
war in ukraine has demonstrated how
dependent russia is on fossil fuel
imports from russia it was uh to the
question of philip lombards at the same
time we're in a situation that inflation
is reaching levels not seen for decades
i think it's 11 point something percent
in my own member states and our families
and smes are already feeling the
consequences of these incredibly high
energy prices
how will the commission ensure in this
economic environment that we couldn't
have foreseen when fit45 was put on the
table um that we will deliver on fit45
with the objectives that we have for
2030 2050 will that be business as usual
as foreseen at the time of publication
or are adaptations may be needed thank
you
rightly so you were mentioning the high
energy prices as really pressing
families and businesses
what is the high energy price and high
electricity price all about
as you know
rightly so
i think 20 years ago when we designed
the common energy and electricity market
it was decided that first of all the
renewables at that time a small share
were pushed into the electricity market
and then the other
the different other kinds of energy are
following and at the very end comes in
the most expensive energy source
but this most expensive energy source
that comes into the market then is
defining the price
this was well designed
for a time where there were little
renewables and lots of gas
today it's different
if you look at the figures they are very
different in different member states but
overall
there's an enormous push forward for the
renewables and they are cost efficient i
mean once uh in place the costs are tiny
then you have topics like the nuclear
that is coming in then you have other
energy sources and in the very end
gas not a big share anymore is coming in
and dominating the price
so if there's anything we have to do to
relieve the families and the business
sector is we have to work on the gas
price
and
there are two options we have given
recommendation for short-term measures a
toolbox member states are using
but in the mid and long term the one
topic is get rid of fossil fuels this is
also get rid of gas we've discussed that
the other topic is look at the
composition of the energy market is it
really still appropriate that it is
dominated by the gas price with all the
consequences or is a time to think of a
new
future model that is fit for purpose
also
with the new reality that we are all
investing in and moving towards more we
as much renewables as possible
and having said that we'll deliver on
that actually
uh mid-may
with a detailed plan so-called re-power
eu on that
having said that this is implicitly of
course
also
advocating
that fit for 55
with the goal
to honor the european green deal and the
climate law that we have
that we have
concluded altogether
is absolutely the right way to go of
course now it's in the hands of the
parliament and of the council also to
find the right balance but the general
direction the general direction must be
get rid of gas get rid of fossil fuels
and go into all the topics that you are
dealing with in fit455 ester you want to
come back
very quickly
thank you for that reply and of course
that will bear fruit in the medium to
long term but at the same time i have
vulnerable households in the netherlands
but also in germany also in romania and
all our member states
where families are putting the heating
even though it's freezing outside on 16
because because they can't afford
anymore and you promised
change that would leave nobody behind
and had you asked me at the time uh i
would have said that fit45 is
challenging you know in terms of
legislation in terms of technical issues
and socially i would at this moment say
the biggest challenge is the social
challenge and how can you
how can we
together deliver on that promise of
leaving nobody behind we have the social
climate fund is it enough
so in the very very short term we've
presented measures to the member states
really to leave nobody behind
um that is for example that you work on
the retail price that you tax the
windfall
profits that are without any question
there
member states do that
and we leave thus
vulnerable households or small
businesses it's happening in the member
states themselves
but you're right in the midterm
this transition from fossil fuels into
renewables has to be accompanied by a
social climate fund we have made
proposals how to get there how to fund
it and the principle is very simple
there are
incomes that of course can afford to
move easily into the new clean way to
use energy but their households it's
impossible for them to do that and these
households need
the support of all of us and this is
embedded in the social climate fund
thank you very much mohammed shaheem is
next
thank you thank you chair
dear president from the liar
two and a half years ago you shared with
us
you shared with us your vision on the
european green deal and called us our
man on the moon project
you've had the full support of snd on
this however we can only call the green
dealer success when we finish it as a
whole and that is what my group has
signed in for
lately we have seen some adjustments in
the timeline some legislative files have
been postponed some even twice yes we
understand that when we are dealing with
unprecedented situation and skyrocketing
energy prices and some see this as the
perfect excuse to delay but the climate
crisis cannot be posed the biodiversity
crisis cannot be posed so my question to
you madam president can you agree that
our man on the moon project will only
succeed when we have a complete european
green deal do you agree that we are in a
biodiversity crisis and desperately need
the nature restoration law and the
revision of the sustainable use of
pesticides directive and can you explain
to us why this is postponed twice thank
you president
both will be tabled before the summer
so here um and i can basically underline
every a word that you've said i mean
the the drama of the climate crisis is
the so-called horizon
we all know that
because it seems to be so far away it is
not far away at all at all but because
it seems so far away it is so difficult
to keep the attention and the urgency
high
uh what that topic is concerned it's our
responsibility to do that it's our
responsibility to tell people
also the difference they are look can
look forward with the european green
deal with a successful fight against
climate change but also what might
happen if we are not successful
and we all remember the last summer for
example i don't have to go into details
anymore where we got an idea what it
means and it will happen again and again
the droughts the floodings the
hurricanes with all the catastrophes
that are coming along this will haunt us
if we don't move on fast and efficient
so you have my support support as i said
both
both topics that you're mentioning will
be tabled before the summer
and we all have to work very hard
that besides the
incredible impact
that this war has
on us and
that is besides the fact that it is
taken
rightly so all our attention and all our
energy we don't lose focus on the huge
crisis that is looming in the background
and that is the climate crisis
thank you mohammed you want to come back
a very short follow-up
because i think the latest moment for us
to really still tackle these two very
important issues within this legislative
period
is uh let's say june 2022 so let me just
ask a very simple strict yes or no
question can we expect these two
legislations let's say by 22 june 2022
yes or no
what is the last week of parliament in
summer here we have
is it that week
i mean it's it's postponed to june 22
and i mean summer so i mean summer is
let's say before we go into summer break
it will be table don't i cannot oversee
the date in june but before we go into
summer break it will be tabled
leon there's a play on dates then thank
you
gunnar beck
fin dank could
you yourself called your commission a
geopolitical commission
which would promote the european way of
life and seek to assume a stronger role
for europe in the world now you said
these were long-standing concerns of
yours which in spite would would inspire
your presidency
now in
2014 the
european council adopted regulation 833
which prohibits the sale of
dual goods
to russia
now these are goods we all know
or technology
which may be put to military use now
according to various press reports in
the brussels times and oddly enough also
the deutsche bella
between 2015 and 18 german companies
exported electronic components
which appear to have found their way
into russian drones
and there's also talk
of german sales of depleted uranium now
during the relevant years you were
germany's defense minister
so my question to you is really quite
simple
can you explain to us
why these transactions were approved by
the german economics ministry which i
believe is the agency that approves all
arms exports if they are allowed
and presumably this happened with the
ascent of your ministry the ministry of
defense thank you
so the answer is very simple if they are
allowed you said if they are allowed
it's abiding to the law
i cannot
oversee the
assumptions you have given in your
question but
if they are allowed abiding to the law
the german government has taken the
decision and the agency has then
fulfilled
is there a supplemental question i
presume you don't have one
cancer regulation 883
is quite clear
it says
i think in article 2 it shall be permit
prohibited to sell supply transfer or
export
directly or indirectly dual use goods
and technology
and any items
which
may be intended
in their entirety
or in part
for military use
or for a military end user thank you
uh the president needs a microphone
the sentence afterwards
the sentence before says
uh where there is no sentence it's
recital number seven
in order to ensure that the measures
provided for in this regulation are
effective it should enter into force
immediately
and the sentence afterwards
sire
well where the end user is the russian
military any dual use goods and
technology procured by it shall be
deemed for military use i'm not sure
that advances your case
so this proves that everything was um
was done
abiding to the law
and this concludes my answer
thank you very much this next is
alexander bondra
yeah yeah we see you
turn on this microphone please
604
yeah
it did not work before
uh madame president let me
raise a question on behalf of the ecr
um i think that this putin aggressive
war against ukraine has changed
everything
and the countries which are hit most by
that
are the countries of central and eastern
europe they are hit by
security dimension they must arm so nato
is very helpful here
they are hit by humanitarian
crisis you know
three and a half million refugees were
accommodated in the families not in the
camps of our countries
and uh in the matter of four weeks not
in the matter of one million in a year
like 2015
we are hit by energy crisis uh we are
hit will be hit by food crisis so
and for the timing we just
hear that you know we are going to
punish for the
poland hungary
which it don't bring any result you know
we can see this in the election just
over the weekend so do you have
something positive also
uh for the central and eastern european
countries in the time of uh when when
they are in need of some solidarity
thank you president yes
the central and eastern european
countries and mostly their population is
outstanding impressive
and they are shining example
how to receive the refugees from ukraine
and
therefore they have our full support
we have flexibilized and mobilized 17
billion euros
that can now be used for example for um
health care schooling housing support of
ukrainian refugees
we know that sometimes the procedures
are too long therefore we have
accelerated within the 17 billion euros
3.4 billion euros that can be dispersed
immediately
and afterwards you can
you know prove uh the billing and all
the accounting that has to be done
so um we are very impressed by the
central and eastern european population
the way
um
the population is dealing with
um our ukrainian friends
and they have this full support and this
is a very clear message
thank respect i think it might be also
necessary to say
that
as you mentioned 2015
it shows
that
war refugees
always find protection
in the european union this is a core
principle of the european union and i
have also not forgotten forgotten that
in 2015 there were member states
that protected
the war refugees from syria at that time
thank you very much mr vondra do you
want to come back
[Applause]
yeah
you know now it's
just
80 percent are the little kids
and the remains are their mothers you
know that's a bit different but uh
question the gas you know
you were talking about the common
purchases uh on behalf of the
eu
so what we see now in qatar is just a
run by you know germany italy the member
states to buy the last remaining gas so
uh is commission uh going to qatar
this is not strictly speaking a
follow-up question but if the president
wants to answer you can answer
so um
we share the same
approach to say it's better
to have a joint procurement
because we have an enormous
market power let me give you one figure
um if you look at the pipeline gas
we the european union are purchasing 75
of the global pipeline gas so if we act
as 27 we are really powerful with a lot
of purchasing power and therefore i
recommend to do that together
and what the commission has done is
already agreed with the united states
that for this year we get an additional
15 billion cubic meter of lng which will
replace the russian lng for this year
and from next year on
we will have an additional 50 billion
cubic meter lng which will replace one
third already of the russian gas so you
see the commission is active
thank you very much next is martin
schildemann
the fender
[Music]
[Music]
thank you next
thank you madam chair uh madam president
it is very good that you will be
triggering the conditionality regulation
on hungary it's a bit unfortunate that
the door is closed when the horse has it
will you make the same mistake with
poland
despite the fact that the polish
government has no intention to even meet
the conditions we hear rumors that the
commission is ready to approve the rrf
plan and to release the funds can you
state here in a very clear simple and
unambiguous yes or no will you or will
you not travel to warsaw on the 9th of
april and approve the plans and free the
way for the release of funds would you
agree with me that such a decision would
be a slap in the face of the polish
people standing up against autocracy and
would you agree with me that it would
also mean reducing the rulings of the
european court of justice to mere
non-binding recommendations thank you
thank you president
so you put several questions into uh
into your question where you wanted a
yes or no answer this is impossible
but i will i will i disagree with many
of your uh hypothetic uh
arguments
but i have to say yes i will travel on
the 9th of april to warsaw but not to
approve the rp
but to do a global pledging
for refugees in ukraine and outside
ukraine not only concerning our member
states
but also a global pledging with
the g20 minus one for example
also a global pledging concerning all
the private companies not on the
european union but also globally to
really support the refugees not only in
the european union but also in ukraine
so therefore
that that's one part now uh on the other
part of your question
which is not a yes or no answer um
i was very clear on the
mid july i think it was here in the
plenary that we discussed what other
conditions for the
polish rp
it's the long-standing requirement in
the european semester independence of
the judiciary and here we look at three
reform requirements
the one is dismantling the disciplinary
chamber
the second one is the reform of the
disciplinary regime and the third one is
the process to reinstall the unlawfully
dismissed judges where does it come from
it is part of a ecg ruling
and with all the member states we have
always been very clear
there are reform requirements you have
to fulfill
then there is the disbursement of the
investment
you do not have to do everything 100
we don't ask any member state for the
100 pension reform or the 100 labor
market reform but long-standing major
requirements of the european semester
you have to do these are the three
requirements we want to see in um the
rrp fulfilled
how could it be fulfilled
the polish government has to bring a law
through
um the parliament
that fulfills these three criterias
we're not there yet just to make that
clear we are close but we're not there
yet
and when the criterias are fulfilled
then
um or when the the the the law is has
passed um the parliament then we look
whether this law is fit for perfect
purpose to fulfill these three criterias
i was just naming initially
if that is the case
so a milestone is reached
then a disbursement can start
this is the process we're not there yet
therefore on the 9th of april i'm going
to be in warsaw for the pledging thank
you sophie do you want to come back
quickly
yes thank you
of course support to poland for the
reception of refugees is uh that is not
a debate but what you're saying is the
rule of no law is non-negotiable
but we can negotiate on the way it is
implemented
i have heard in recent weeks too much
speculation about what that means in
practice madam president three years ago
you asked for our confidence when there
is so much speculation there cannot be
confidence i would really ask you to be
crystal clear about what it is what the
criteria are that the commission will
apply i think this house and the
citizens the citizens of poland the
citizens of hungary indeed the citizens
of all the 27 member states have a right
to know exactly what the standards are
thank you
the standards are dismantling of the
disciplinary chamber
a reform of the disciplinary regime
process to reinstall the unlawfully
dismissed judges this is the core of the
ecj judgment
and actually a judgment where poland is
paying a daily fine
right
now
for not fulfilling this order of the ecj
so we've taken that as a very clear
benchmark
we want this reform done
the best way to have this reform done is
have a law that has gone through the
parliament where we then can look
whether it fulfills it is fit for
purpose it fulfills the criteria
if not the milestone is not fulfilled
if yes the milestone is fulfilled and a
disbursement for the european green deal
for the digitalization for the
resilience can start we're not there yet
but i described as you wanted the
process
thank you very much uh madam president
do you have time for one more question
sven
um
[Music]
raw materials critical minerals
thank you
sven we don't have too much time
thank you uh if we try to squeeze in as
much as possible but commission
president would like you thank you for
giving us more time
than we originally asked for thanks for
apologies for the technical problems but
i think this for a question time first
time did very well after 12 years since
this has last taken place in this
plenary
a lot of you colleagues have asked to
take the floor can i ask you to still
register your questions for the next
question time with the high
representative if those questions can be
put to him thank you very much